hello everybody
welcome thank you for coming to the 61st
annual
edward hugh memorial lecture we're
really happy to have you here partly
because we did not do this lecture last
year due to covid um so this is a bit of
a reopening for us and we're really
especially happy to see you um you can
learn more about the human dr hume on
the back of your brochure here um he was
a physician he was a yale college
graduate he spent a good part of his
career in china where he founded this
young hospital
and medical school
and has a connection to the yale china
association i think some of our yale
china association friends are here
tonight um
but yes as i said we're very happy to
have you um i know a few people are
still making their way in please note
this lecture is being recorded um so if
you ask a question you may show up on
the audio uh which will be posted to our
youtube channel um afterwards if you
know anybody who missed it please let
them know that it's being recorded and
will be posted um and so yeah without uh
further ado i will turn it over to arno
astad the elihu professor of history who
will introduce our guest speaker thank
you
thank you richard
so it's a great pleasure for me to
introduce my friend professor ron omita
who is going to be speaking to us today
for the 61st june lecture
with the title like kite flies against
the wind internationalism
uh identity and ideology in the shaping
of post-war china and a legacy for today
so rona is professor of history and
politics in modern china at oxford
university he's a fellow
of saint cross college
he was the inaugural director of the
oxford china center from 2013 to
to 2020
when he made a his escape from that one
in order to do more books i'm sure
um he has done quite a few already i'm
not going to mention all of them here
right now but i'm just going to
highlight some of those that have been
particularly influential in terms of
professor meta's work
um
a bitter revolution
china's struggle with the modern world
which is his survey of 20th century
china
and probably the best one that is
available now was published in 2004.
um his book forgotten ally as it was
published under the title of here
forgotten ally china's world war ii
published in 2013
uh is certainly the most distinguished
uh history of china's
world war ii the anti-japanese war as
most chinese will will know it know it
as and one that has had a tremendous
reception
when it came out
and most recently a book entitled
china's good war
how world war ii is shaping a new
nationalism which came out now almost
two years ago
now that last book
i think sets some of the background
for the for the lecture today at least
in terms of some of the questions asked
and i must say
when i read that book i saw it as a
tremendous success because it was able
to do many things at the same time it
was able to
present
a an updated history of how many chinese
viewed anti-japanese war we know as the
second world war
but it was also able to deal with memory
and identification and project that
forward
to today in terms of how
the memory of that war
the identities created by that play and
inference
have a strong influence today
our colleague here at yale
jay winter
wrote in a a review
of the book that
shows movingly what chinese people sing
about and weep about
when they turn their minds to the
devastating contours of the second world
war
equally at home in provincial museums
internet chat rooms and china's foreign
ministry mitter is a sure guide to
china's ongoing reassessment of the war
and post-war his brilliant account
jss
shows how nation has replaced class in
the moral narrative china has
constructed to frame its national
project and i think that's a really good
summing up of these of the strengths and
the significance of the book
so rana in his work is first and
foremost i would argue as student of
chinese nationalism in its in its
various forms starting out with his
early work on manchuria and then going
all the way up to his work on chinese
politics in the in the 21st century and
as many people he will know some better
than me
dealing with concepts of chinese
nationalism is a really difficult topic
and i'm sure we're going to hear more
about that today rona has really put his
stamp on the historical discussion and
his geographical discussion but also the
contemporary discussion about these the
the format the significance and the role
of of chinese nationalism and he's been
able to do that because he's not just an
historian doing fantastic work at oxford
rana is also
a leading british public intellectual
not just on issues relating to china but
on issues of history and contemporary
international affairs
um in general
and the impact that he has had on this
has been tremendous i uh having taught
in britain for a very long time and even
after coming to this country i'm amazed
to see how many people you've influenced
including a lot of people who do not
work on china
in terms of how they understand
the
the contemporary
world so we
are really very lucky to have you
working in this field i i picked up
just before
uh you came here i
i was trying to put together this
presentation run and i've had a recent
interview with you where you
outlined how you got interested in china
in the first place and
i just wanted to quote a bit of that in
conclusion so you say this interview
in the late 1980s and early 1990s china
was a tremendously remote place
in terms of british perceptions
india has always for imperial reasons
been the ancient connection that's been
stronger in britain
so this was a combination of a very
challenging but interesting language
i can certainly subscribe to that
but also a culture that perhaps had as
little to do with the things i've grown
up with as could possibly be imagined
and although in later decades china has
come much closer to us that was by no
means obvious
so it was a leap in the dark
but not one that i've regretted at any
point
well neither have you run or who
followed your work and learned from your
work uh over
now quite a long career in in the study
of china i think it is the most
fortuitous choice that you made back
then
for all of those of us who have
benefited from your
your writing from from
both your early books and the books that
you produced most most recently
it might not have been an immediate
choice at the time but it it certainly
was a good one so
with that let us all welcome professor
onometer
before i do anything else in this covid
age i should ask richard is this bottle
of water for my use or
excellent very good indeed
always best check on these these matters
could i start by saying thank you very
much to everyone who has come in person
to this event and i know these days that
agreeing to come in person to event has
its own freestyle around it so i'm very
grateful that you've all chosen to join
us this this afternoon
and could i also start if i may with
a couple of thanks um i'm very grateful
to the committee who chose me to give
the edward hugh memorial lecture i know
having looked at some of the history
that not only was edward hume himself
clearly one of the many distinguished
yale graduates who made their mark in
and connected to china but also i felt
suitably uh humbled by the range of very
distinguished scholars who have given
this uh beforehand so i am aware of the
um
uh the honor that it's done to me by
inviting me here for that i'd also like
to thank richard stephanie kim and all
the others who have done the rather
complex arrangements to actually bring
someone from britain to america
something which used to be quite simple
to arrange but now has its own
complexities
i'd also like if i may say briefly a
word to two scholars one is my very old
friend professor arnavestad uh whose
work i like i think frankly most of the
field of modern history have been
learning from for the last 25 to 30
years not to remind you iron about how
long you've been educating us all for
but i think it is fair to say that in
terms of everything from the history of
postwar china a subject on which today
i'm going to touch with and i hope in
some ways engage with some of the
agendas that arena has challenged our
field with but also well beyond that in
terms of the global cold war and a whole
variety of what we might call the
history of our own era a field in which
honor i think is genuinely an unmatched
historian his departure from the uk a
few years ago was a great loss to us but
it was an immense gain not only to uh to
yale but also i think to the wider field
on which he is now able to to stride i'd
also like to if i may give a brief word
to a scholar who is not here but i think
is here in a wider sense and that is of
course the late jonathan spence i only
met jonathan spence a couple of times
one i'm glad to say was actually here at
yale university when he uh was kind
enough to come and listen to a talk that
i uh i gave
but i have told many times before and
will very briefly tell the story of in
that early phase that arne arno
mentioned when i was thinking as a
school boy in england
what subject i might wish to study at
university
one of the books that fell to my hand in
fact first book that i ever read in
chinese history was the gate of heavenly
peace the chinese in their revolution
the sweeping panoramic story of what i
now think of i didn't know it then but
what i now think of as the may fourth
generation and the revolution that they
made and i still have that rather
battered penguin copy which i bought in
a bookstore in brighton england uh quite
easily to hand in the study that i have
today i've realized to my horror
probably something like three and a half
decades after i i bought it so although
of course jonathan spence is no longer
with us here at yale he is of course
someone whose reputation will live for a
very long time in the field and i'm
personally very glad to have learned
from him also
so a lot to live up to today and i will
do my best but forgive me
if following in the footsteps of various
giants i may stumble now and then
but i think we should start if i may
with some of the bigger events that have
been shaping understanding of chinese
history in the last few weeks and months
before we returned to a period slightly
longer ago and this is where i hope that
the technology is going to allow us to
follow this yes
particularly in this audience you may
have paid some attention to the
promulgation of the resolution on
certain questions in the party's history
that was passed through the sixth plenum
of the chinese communist party in
beijing
and officially announced just a few
months ago in fact in november of 2021.
you will have seen if so that the
resolution does certain things
it seals the historical status as one
sees in the posters here of xi jinping
as china's leader placing him in a very
direct and uh high profile trajectory
from mao zedong through tang xiaoping
again all of them portrayed as you see
there in the poster on the uh the the
right hand side
um and then through the other leaders
onto
xi jinping
those two previous leaders though mao
and dong were the only ones associated
with previous such resolutions in the
party's history uh
one was of course the more recent uh
deng xiaoping back in 1981 just 40 or 41
years ago whose resolution essentially
was an admission of at least partial
responsibility
for the cultural revolution
but the previous resolution all the way
back in 1945
was promulgated just as the war with
japan was coming to an end and it helped
ma zedong to confirm the leadership of
his party which had been a work in
process but very much consolidating by
that time and that of course was a
resolution that also laid down the
ground even before the civil war that
would eventually bring uh mao and his
party to victory
and i want to turn back to that date in
particular to
1945
and talk a little bit about how i think
that that moment
should be rediscovered in terms of
understanding not only i think some of
the significance of the history of that
moment but also where it links to the
present day
and i want to do that
by putting forward
an argument that the factors that
underpinned the struggle for order and
the means of achieving that order
have important parallels for a story
that emerges at that time but which we
are still living with in a different
form in the present day
and that is the story of the rise of a
global
china
and a china that thinks about itself
and thinks about its place in the world
in some very particular ways
and for reasons of organization and
convenience but i hope ones that will
make some sense i've divided that into
three areas of examination
all of which conveniently begin with the
letter i internationalism
ideology and identity
and the moment the period the era in
which i want to place them
is a period that i started to call the
chinese post-war
this is of course a reference to the
years after world war ii but it's also
attempt to try and popularize the use of
the term post-war in other words
post-second world war post-anti-japanese
war in the chinese context in a way that
is entirely mainstream and
uncontroversial in the european context
as the late tony jutt for one would have
would have put forward and of course in
the form of single in the japan the [ __ ]
sorry the japan history field where it's
been a well-known term the chinese
equivalent john holt has of course
existed for a long time but it doesn't
have quite i think the um
capacity to encompass a range of ideas
about a period as opposed to a literal
statement of the the period itself in a
way there's other terms do and so i am
putting it forward at this point it is
of course a period
about which arnold vestad has written
with immense distinction the period of
the chinese civil war 1946 to
1950 and if you didn't think the chinese
civil went until 1950 you should check
out hainan island where of course it did
uh
last until quite late into that uh that
year
but i would say that also of course it
is much more than the period of the
chinese civil war devastating and
central though that was
it was also the time when china moved
into the first phase of its engagement
with the post-war international order
and i speak of course today on a day
when uh largely to do with events in
eastern europe rather than east asia the
nature of that post order already
somewhat fragile for
for good reasons is becoming even more
in question
as the hours and the days
go by
it's also of course a moment when china
sought a new definition of its own
sovereignty as a founder member of the
united nations and of course a permanent
member of the newly formed security
council
it was also a time when china became
embroiled in some of the biggest global
debates
about the links between economic and
social development
it was also a time when ideological
concerns did i think come to the
forefront there were huge debates in
china in those post-war years about what
democracy might actually mean in the
chinese context
and of course huge debates about what
relationship if any that type of
democracy had to the growing and
ultimately inexorable forces in china's
deep countryside
in other words
it was a time when some of the debates
were remarkably similar to those of
today
and in other important ways remarkably
different
the china of xi jinping i should be
clear is not in any argument that i will
make the same as the china that matadong
took over in 1949. today's china is
global in reach whereas that china was
recovering from the afterma aftermath of
two huge wars first with japan and then
of course between the chinese themselves
today's china is i think indubitably a
consumerist society the earlier version
was very much about austerity
today's china is an innovator in
technology that earlier version was
desperate to find support whether from
the soviets or from the americans to
create it create its own ecology of
development that will become autonomous
over time but could not start in that
way
so the differences are
clear
but the continuities
do matter
to understand why that would be you just
have to look at the process that was
going on to produce the resolution on
the party's history
and um
the uh the key word in that perhaps
unsurprisingly is the word history in
other words the ccp the chinese
communist party cares deeply that its
own
version of its own story of origin is
dominant without any of the nasty bumps
in the road uh vicious intra-party
massacres the famine the great leap
forward the turmoil of the cultural
revolution that in practice have been
part of the historical nexus
of events that have brought it to
power and you can see that i won't go
through the whole thing you'll be glad
to know but here are a few key quotes
from the uh authorized english
translation of the original
text as as issued
i go into that detail
because although we have a relatively
limited time today i think it is fair to
say that that history is becoming of
increasing interest both in china itself
and in the wider world and actually in
some ways the interest is a bifurcated
one
one is a series of questions of interest
within the historical profession and in
today's comments when i get some detail
in just just a moment i think it's fair
to say that those debates are ones that
i think historians are primarily
concerned with and which i think can
help us rethink beyond china this period
of global history
but the other set of concerns is very
much an engagement with the ideas that
shape china's contemporary politics and
i give you this short if somewhat dense
extract from the party resolution of
2021 simply to point out the chinese
communist party in its present
incarnation however future oriented
however keen it is on creating a
forward-looking socio-economic contract
is still immensely concerned with the
way in which its past is constructed in
its own eyes and in the eyes of um of
others
so to give you some illustration of how
that continuity as well as change works
i've drawn on historical materials
relating to various individuals with i
think
important insights into the geopolitical
and ideological change during that
period
i'm not going to talk today very much
about
the very what you might kind of call
called top tier of of leaders mao zedong
chiang kai-shek and others i've written
about them elsewhere and you know many
others who have done wonderful work on
uh what they were doing during this
period
instead i want to draw on some voices
that i think are less well known
although i think they are quite central
in terms of what they illustrate to the
dynamics of that post-war moment in
china and i have to confess i've chosen
them also because they allowed me to
indulge what i personally have found one
of the most rewarding parts of
examination of historical development
during this time which is the diaries
kept by very large numbers of figures
not only of world historical importance
but also quite local inward-looking
importance day after day i think uh
ireland may agree that historians of
china give thanks for the confucian
tendencies that led very large numbers
of china chinese even into the mid 20th
century to keep very extensive diaries
of their own thoughts and doings and
those have been very valuable to all of
us who want to reconstruct
that particular
past
and
i will show
a couple of pictures of two of the
figures who i wanted to uh bring up i
will bring up
on the left-hand side i figure i've said
he was sort of less famous than some of
the others but actually at the time uh
pretty distinguished one shadier
during the time that i'm talking about
the foreign minister of china but also a
constitutional lawyer one of that
extraordinary generation of young
chinese almost all but not entirely but
almost all men who were sent to study
overseas mostly in the united states
some of them in britain
and who became fluent not just in
english and chinese but actually fluent
into world views as well and i think
that that is something which until
recently um has been uh forgotten and
perhaps under appreciated
um on the right-hand side uh drawing
actually here on memoirs rather than
diaries but i think very very vivid ones
in in many ways is
during the post-war years she was a
young communist activist she joined the
revolution when she was just 15 years
old in hunan province she spent most of
the next 20 years essentially on the run
she was a powerful actor in her own
right but i should observe she also
became married to a figure who became
very senior in the ccp politburo
standing committee member uh tao drew
who came to a pretty harrowing end
during the cultural revolution in fact
and
these figures i think are amongst those
who illustrate some of the wider points
that i wanted to make
one should himself as he observed in his
diaries the period of first of all hope
and then despair of the last years of
the gomindang nationalists in government
uh as first of all observing a period
where all sorts of new possibilities had
opened up for china
but also one of the country was deeply
vulnerable bear in mind that in 1945 at
the time of the japanese surrender china
was simultaneously both stronger
and weaker than it had been at any time
in a century stronger because it had the
prestige of being a victorious allied
power alongside the british the
americans the soviets and of course the
french and full sovereignty essentially
the first time since 1843 because of
wartime treaties that have been signed
to end uh various
restrictions on its sovereignty
but at the same time
weak beyond imagining because it was a
country that over the eight years of the
war against the japanese have been
destroyed by bombing
refugee flight
and financial and economic disaster
sanctuary and other
comrades of hers saw this post-war
period as a time of ideological
refashioning when previous assumptions
about mentalities
had to be rethought
it was not enough to rebuild china's
railways and roads you had to refashion
its people as well
and today the reason i bring this up is
that today
it's become quite commonplace to look at
much of china's language political
language official language particularly
at a time when it really matters to know
what the official mind of china thinks
and says
and from a western point of view quite
often that language particularly when
translated directly into english sounds
either highly laden with jargon
or very saccharine or very very
confrontational or indeed aggressive
and
one of the things that i think going
back to some of that period of birth and
development of that sort of political
language is a reminder that yes it is
highly constructed language but that
does not make it inauthentic language
and i think the connection between those
two is very important in terms of
understanding
what people at that time
thought they were doing rather than what
we think they may have been doing at the
time as i will hope
to show you early on in his tenure as
foreign minister he served from 1945
august to uh 1948.
became a part of the chinese negotiation
team with none other than the man that
owner calls the boss in his books uh
joseph stalin
it was pretty much a baptism if it was a
baptism of sorts of fired imagine your
first diplomatic negotiation being with
stalin on the the other end
one shogi knew that it was going to be a
pretty fierce sort of encounter and as
he got on the plane to head to moscow he
kept a little phrase that his daughter
had written for him and although the
diaries are in chinese a few he was a
fluent speaker of english and some
phrases were in english and this one his
daughter had also an english room and
that was the phrase
don't be afraid of opposition
remember a kite flies against not with
the wind and that was the source of my
title for today but i chose it because i
think it was a very appropriate metaphor
for an immensely turbulent
time
let me um
before i get start getting into
some of the the detail of what one
should yeah
and others were saying at this time
i'm sure with this expert audience we
don't need much of this but let me take
about
90 seconds i hope just to give a very
very quick overview of some of the
milestones historically that we see in
china during this time and as i've said
we'll say again if you want more details
you can't do better than to check out um
cold war and revolution and decisive
encounters two books by um arnold who
has pioneered this particular field but
during those five very very crowded
years it's worth noting that the war
which china for japan since 1937 came to
an end
negotiations uh between the uh
nationalists and the um the gomidang and
the soviets
led to a sino-soviet treaty of
friendship in august 1945 that was
essentially an attempt amongst other
things by the chinese nationalists to
close off the soviets to give them
certain concessions in return for them
not attempting further support of their
communist chinese allies or further
territorial demands which included of
course at that time incursions into
xinjiang
as well as into manchuria
china also during this time becomes one
of the permanent five members of the u.n
security council china of course has
been permanently on that council ever
since although of course for a couple of
decades as taiwan rather than as the
mainland until 1971.
and
also during this time you see the
increasingly fraught coalition
negotiations that begin uh in 1945 46
general marshall george marshall spent
most of 1946 ultimately vainly trying to
get a ceasefire and coalition government
between the communists and nationalists
before that broke down
you then have 1946-49 a vicious civil
war between the two sides at first there
was a plausible argument that the
guamidang that the nationalists could
somehow consolidate and destroy the
ccp's political and military base but a
variety of factors turned the tide
everything from
improved communist battle tactics under
limbial and others to the destruction of
the morale and economic base of the
gomindang through poor military choices
and economic chaos eventually the end of
the story of course is well known chiang
kai-shek flees to taiwan and the
communists conquer the mainland by 1949
with hainan island following the next
year
so that is the main narrative of the
civil war and the immensely important
backdrop to other events
but i want to put that if one can do
that slightly aside for a little bit
because it seems to me that we sometimes
act as if a phase in china's foreign
relations
ends in 1949 and starts again from
zero so from mao's china the turn to the
soviet union split from the united
states made final by the korean war and
the continued presence of the roc taiwan
in the united nations until the 1970s
and in that version of history i'm
characterizing slightly but not all that
much in some ways
1945-49 is a sort of stub it's an
afterthought it's unfinished business
that finally gets wrapped up but isn't
of huge importance in its own right
and i'd want to challenge that i think
although a lot did start again evidently
in 1949
some important elements including
china's engagement with the united
nations
and the rivalry between taipei and
beijing which emerged to make links with
other non-western states remained highly
relevant across that 1949
uh boundary
and what makes one [ __ ] the foreign
minister of china interesting in that
time is the thread of things being taken
up or being set up
that would
not be taken up by him in the immediate
short term but would later come back to
become a very important part of china's
self-presentation in that later era of
global
engagement under the ccp i'm talking
about territorial claims uh maritime and
land-based and the wider projection of
china as a power with regional and even
global ambitions
so in his first year in office 1945-46
one should yet became part of at least
three major negotiations the first was
the meeting with uh stalin and moscow to
bring about the sino-soviet uh treaty of
1945 the second was his presence as part
of that team negotiating with american
support for the coalition government
between the communists and the
nationalists
but the third set of discussions related
to areas that have been less covered and
analyzed up to now
and they relate in particular to one
shadier's attempts at a fluid time in
geopolitics to stake a claim
for china as a global player player in
the post-war world to steal the famous
words of u.s secretary of state dean
atchison slightly of all electrics he
wasn't actually secretary of state at
that point
not just to be present at the creation
but also to take a stronger role in
doing the creating of an order that
would stretch across continents
bear in mind that wang
like most chinese officials and elites
whether nationalist or communist
absolutely believe that china's titanic
sacrifices including the 10 million or
more war dead through a variety of
causes military death of course but
famine and
disease as well
and of course china's refusal to
surrender to japan in 1938
their belief that these events had
changed the war and the world now had a
debt
of honor to
china
and this led to a whole variety of
approaches
some at the more seemingly quixotic end
of what might be geopolitically possible
in other words one's pushing of the idea
of china being a power that might not
just reshape asia i'll say more about
that in a moment but also europe as well
and wong shiger pushed repeatedly for
china to get a place at that table of
european negotiation
that was as i say at the further end of
his ambition at the time more achievable
in the short term was a desire to find a
new mode of engagement with other
countries in the emergent non-western
post-colonial world china saw itself
potentially as a mentor to many of them
but also of course in the case of
countries like india in particular a
rival or an alternative leader and one's
daily negotiations show many aspects of
those as we will see
the principle that
if the west could still make decisions
for asia in 1945 as indeed it was doing
in vietnam in malaya in a whole variety
in korea in a whole variety of other uh
in japan indeed um of polities in the
region
then
likewise asia should be able to have a
role in shaping the west it might seem
as i say an ambition beyond anything
that was realistic but its logic clearly
appealed deeply to wang shujir's mind
and indeed hard
and that led him i will say to some
rather awkward conversations uh one is
uh illustrated as it were here in his
engagement with the
then uh soviet um foreign minister
vyacheslav molotov uh if you think that
the current foreign minister of russia
sergey lavrov is something of a hard
case molotov clearly set the mold and i
think in fact is a related through
family too he was a grand marriage to
the grandson i think or something anyway
so there's a family connection between
the the two it must be uh it must be
said
and arriving in september 1945 at the
london foreign ministers conference one
of wang xijia's first priorities was to
try and grab some of the big foreign
ministers of that time uh ernest bevin
of britain uh james burns the secretary
of state of the united states and
molotov he didn't get very far with them
but nonetheless he pressed his case
strongly where he felt he could do so
pushing the case for instance with
molotov that um a trusteeship for the
north african colonies such as libya
which had been left behind by italy
should be uh discussed in a much more
open and full way than was being planned
at the time and also various plans for
the joint management potentially of the
governance of post-war uh post-war japan
molotov was very keen on that idea one
should have cooled on it quite quickly
realizing that to do so would almost
certainly alienate the united states but
it was by no means a um a foolish
request on the part of molotov since he
could clearly see the attractiveness of
putting forward an option that would
give the soviets more say in japan but
would also attract china by giving them
a role as opposed to everything
essentially being decided by the united
states
it's clear also from the negotiations
as recorded that why should you put
forward viewpoints and thoughts that
drew very much from his own and china's
own experience during the past two
decades
i think the memories of manchuria being
invaded in 1931 were very much in his
mind when he argued against a proposal
by the french to separate off part of
northern germany in the post-war
negotiations one said in his diary i
said that it wasn't right if the people
who lived in that region didn't desire
to separate from germany
then if the people who lived in that
region didn't desire to separate from
germany
i talked about the principle of
nationalism
which should not be neglected even on
the territory of your enemy now that's
an interesting statement particularly
for the foreign minister of a country
that had suffered as much as china had
at that point but also a sign of the i
think genuinely quite forward-looking
thinking that was going on not about
just what had happened in terms of the
immense destruction visited on china but
what the world that was coming was going
to look like
he also went on very explicitly to say
his words china could not be excluded
from discussions of the balkans or
italy i have to say molotov's reply was
essentially oh yes china can be excluded
and indeed pretty much went on to to do
that but again the point is that wang
was not simply refusing to put to
taking what he could get he was very
keen to make sure that the case was put
forward and that china's argument that
it should be a power that at least had
some say in global matters beyond the
asian sphere was on the record at that
point it has to be said that uh
secretary burns didn't entirely
resist uh the idea although part of that
was clearly to do with trying to make
sure that there was a sort of balance
between the various powers all of whom
wanted to get a certain role and china
inevitably of course was on the weaker
end of that particular spectrum
the following year uh when the foreign
ministers met in paris in 1946
wang shijia was forced by that stage in
a way that had been less necessary in 45
to talk about and to some extent make
excuses for the continuing failure of
his government to
resolve the civil war situation but his
earlier lobbying did actually pay off
and china at this conference was given a
certain amount of time to speak about
the european situation
uh one argued that the reparations for
peace treaties being drawn up mustn't be
too harsh so as to avoid as he put it
reactionary forces in the defeated
countries reviving and democratic forces
being unable to rise and again in a
moment in a day indeed when the anger of
powers that consider that they have been
placed outside the international order
is being felt
just across the atlantic in europe at
the moment we can see once again that
these sorts of sentiments from 1945-46
well at some level clearly very much
tied to that historical moment are by no
means absent in terms of that wider
principle of establishing uh
establishing order
now my point here is not and there are
various other things of course you
talked about including the question of
italy's colonies the soviet refusal to
withdraw from iran and a whole variety
of other factors that emerged at that
time
my point here is not that china was a
major actor in shaping the balkan or
italian settlements clearly it wasn't i
think that would be a point of
historical revisionism too far
what i think is important is the
narrative of entitlement whether or not
he got what he wanted wang sijiye at
that point saw no reason why he should
not make a claim for china as a wartime
allied victorious power to be part of
the establishment of that global order
and while the point of origin and the
point of justification is some ways
different today the fact that today a
rather different china makes claims not
just obviously in its own backyard but
in new areas including the arctic does
show that the idea of china thinking of
itself as a power that has global reach
is something that has a much longer
history than is sometimes uh assumed
when the belt and road initiative if you
know starting seven or eight years ago
is thought of as a sort of of year zero
in other words china's policymakers saw
this as part of a trajectory which at
that time they were projecting into a
world that will continue from their
point of view from the 1940s 50s and
beyond they did not know at that stage
although they quickly found out that
their own particular world would come to
an end in 1949
but it didn't mean of course that their
successors couldn't take advantage of
what they had to say
and let me give an example of something
closer to home from china and
washington's point of view that i think
makes the point quite clearly because
while i've put forward one xujir's
attempts to try and influence the
european settlement as perhaps the
furthest reach that he might have tried
in terms of uh making a claim for a new
global china the asian sphere was not
only an area where actually there was
much greater success even in a
relatively short period but also one
where the sponsoring powers in
particular the united states were much
happier to allow a greater chinese role
and this became quite clear in terms of
the initiatives that china took in some
areas where it felt that it had newly
earned rights
so let's take one [ __ ] here looking a
little closer to home on the shisha the
paracel islands in 1947. now i bring
this particular subject up again because
again in this audience i think it's fair
to say that you'll be aware that the
problem of chinese claims on the south
china sea is by no means of only
historical interest i will not say
anything more about rights or wrongs or
yeses or knows about any present day
claims but i will read if i may um a
short extract from his diary the 18th of
january 1947
which says something about the way in
which um why she
was looking to put forward
a new narrative of china's rights in
asia
in this case pitched as an anti-colonial
move because the power that
was at that stage
in the chinese sites when it came to
repossession of the islands in this case
was colonial france which wanted to
reclaim these particular islands
essentially as part of their vietnamese
colony
and washington wrote in his diary we've
always claimed the shisha archipelago
archipelago as our territory so there's
chris to the middle of today's some prc
making historical claims on the uh on
the seas but once your deal continues
but we've never yet set up officials or
sent workers to stay there on a regular
basis and again in the present days
there's lots of debates about whether or
not these islands have been inhabited
and having people actually live on them
the french government recognizes it he
says as vietnamese territory
after japan's surrender we sent a small
number of troops to the important island
at the heart of the archipelago it's
called woody island to
occupy it
recently the french have sent a military
ship to the island to scare our troops
resident there but after my intervention
they withdrew
this is going to be a dispute between
china and france
well i can say that last sentence
probably has not come out as being the
the major historical
element that was ultimately of
importance but all the rest of that i
think does indicate the way in which the
claims
and the desire to reorder
the asian sphere that was in china's
influence was very much at the heart of
the gomindang project in the immediate
post-war well before the communist
victory in 1944
49
and that happened again it didn't that
doesn't happen out of context it happens
during uh months and years when a whole
variety of different
visitors come to nanjing the chinese
capital to negotiate for a new uh order
in asia
in 1946 the former pri thai prime
minister predi bangla visits after the
treaty with thailand
as one said the first time an important
key figure from thailand has visited
china in this way april 1947 was quite
busy singh munree came in from korea
as
wang said his thinking is a bit
conservative which i think is a bit of
an understatement but it's some fair
fair analysis but his spirit of struggle
is very strong uh and um he was rather
rather a fan of of re and then the
philippines despite the disputes over
south china sea more broadly speaking in
this case a treaty of friendship is set
up between the chinese and the um
and the philippine government just after
the philippines gained independence
in other words
much more of the configuration of order
is being done by asians with other
asians at this point then has perhaps
been appreciated not to the exclusion of
the superpower conflict that emerges at
that time and not to the exclusion of
the horrific domestic turmoil that is
tearing china apart but at the same time
and it's the confluence of these
particular forces that i think deserves
further further examination in terms of
their simultaneous uh simultaneous
actions
so let me move on from that point if i
may for the last section of what i want
to do to talk about a rather different
area of engagement i have been ranging
in the last
quarter
in terms of this attempt to try and
rewrite a little bit the geopolitical
project of china in this immediate
post-war era
but i now want to sort of almost zoom in
the other direction and look very much
inside hearts and minds to understand
what was going on in terms of changing
and political thinking at this
particular sense that's where i bring
together what i've called the other two
eyes the ideology and the identity of
what's going on and again not that
everything in the past should reflect
the present but at a time when huge
amounts of effort is spent on reading
chinese documents chinese social media
i'd say actually csis in washington dc i
believe is just about to start a major
new online project in terms of analysis
of key chinese documents which has
actually a very 1960s air to it for
those of us who know where the field
emerged from although i personally
wasn't around i have to say during that
particular particular moment but that
idea in other words that you can read an
awful lot into how people construct
language
particularly marxist phrases and
language
is i think one that has a much longer
and very interesting
history
in other words we know a great deal
about ideology in terms of what was
taught to converts to a particular
ideological cause but sometimes i think
the missing link
is to see how detailed the socialization
was of that belief into links to
objective reality i mean as i'm saying
quite marxist here but what i meant was
that these linguistic changes and ways
of thinking do not happen in a vacuum i
mean how could they happen in vacuum
they happen in the context of historical
events and people use political terms
and language constructed language that
comes from elsewhere
to shape their own lived subjective
experience
and you know terms like lived subjective
experience again
jargon for academics
we're talking here about extraordinary
people let's go back to zungjur who i
showed you at the beginning
so as i said at the age of 15
in 1926
she went on to a turbulent she joined a
turbulent life that went on and on in
underground
ccp politics in her own words she was
quote a career revolutionary
she killed her first landlord with a
spear through his stomach in 1927.
that's an interesting part of her
memoirs i can tell you
um and she sat within a grouping a
generation of people of different ages
and different stages all of whom came
became part of this new and
transformative political project
a couple more here may be known to you
uh possibly but in case not
uh on the left hand side at yangci
khadra at this time in the post four
years in his 40s mostly based in jojang
in east central china mid-level officer
not super high but not a junior guy
either and on the um
right hand side there uh leo yan jin
the youngest of any of these um
these people born at 25 just in her
early 20s as the 1949 revolution
approached
let's have a look at some of the diary
entries of yang si who again does
historians a huge favor by writing not
quite day-to-day but certainly every few
days as he is engaged in the campaign
that ultimately becomes part of the um
victorious campaign for
the conquest of the mainland
and one of the things that's very
obvious from what he writes at the time
is that there was nothing natural
nothing automatic about local
people becoming attracted to the ccp
now historians might say on the on the
one hand that actually it's fairly
obvious there's nothing natural about
that sort of thing but of course there
is so much language about the idea of
the masses being naturally attracted to
this transformative social force that
swept away the hated
you know you can fill in the words for
yourself it's well worth noting that the
day-to-day experience was clearly often
quite uh quite different
um one
of many very interesting entries from
october 1945 is when youngsi takes part
in account of personnel
and weapons because so many people are
deserting at that point from the base
area that he's in in in jojang as part
of the newly formed
communist armies
they end up at that particular point
with um
several hundred people out of about two
thousand troops deserting uh yang
observing as he says because of the
changes in their life situation in other
words being recruited and placed in this
this military formation everyone got
quite worried and then
he adds the following note
the majority are good comrades
there are many reasons for such a
serious reduction of numbers by which he
means desertion
but the leaders and the section chiefs
have not united the warlord residue of
their leadership style and their
emotional complicity
by dragging people basically into
projects they don't fully agree with or
or
approve of are the main reasons
the military leaders and the political
commanders don't get on well and of
course the question of political links
and military links in the top leadership
and also the kind of next levels down
of the people's liberation army as it
formed under that name and reformed
itself is one of the most interesting
things in terms of how you bring
together often very disparate groups of
people and turn them into an effective
fighting force but also political force
so he says the military leaders and the
political commanders don't get on well
and this reflects abnormality between
the party and the masses i think that's
both an interesting and indeed quite
honest statement because much of what
then takes place and this is 1945 as you
see
what happens during much the next two
three four years is a continuing attempt
to try and make sure there is some way
in which as the military situation
improves the political socialization of
those both in the pla and associated
with the pla becomes much stronger
because their point of contrast of
course is the increasing collapse of the
guamindang armies and the records that
we have from people recruited in those
at lower levels are very much of
increasing realization of lack of
organization corruption and failure to
ultimately achieve their various uh
various ends
and
the monitoring of the political
ideological and indeed emotional
temperature of the charges of a pla
officer like yang see
is of course
very different in all sorts of obvious
ways from the process of
entering into the party in the present
day but the overall aim the aim to try
and make sure that the political and the
emotional and the professional are
brought together is in some ways a very
very similar one even though today for
the most part it's not in a military
context even though of course
the ethos of militarization is one of
the things that we have noted has become
much stronger in chinese civil society
and the media sphere in the last um few
years
and youngsee himself also did something
that again from what we know about party
practice today
is still very current which is
self-reflection
his partner was a performer in the
entertainment division of the of the pla
and the relationship is not always going
terribly terribly well and he writes
about himself in his diary um
i suddenly felt kind of that my life was
very narrow and quite depressing he says
these pretty bourgeois feelings being
too thick
or too
intense it's not good i want to change
that in myself now to those of us
sitting here in an anglophone country in
the 2020s talking about your own pretty
bourgeois feelings sounds you know at
best artificial and possibly even you
know slightly ludicrous
the point here is that for someone who
was feeling something that was clearly
emotionally quite genuine
in this context the appropriate way to
express it was through a particular type
of as in this case marxist influence
political language that helped him to
both express and process and justify
what it is that he wanted to do and this
became a much more common practice
throughout the whole of the political
project of that particular uh particular
era in mid-july of that uh of that uh
year 1946
young reflected further on what he
called his two big flaws
and he says
when someone hurts my purty bourgeois
self-regard i lose patience or at least
i feel unhappy inside his the answer as
far as he was concerned was as he put it
political study and daily self
reflection which combines both marxism
and confucianism i think in a rather a
kind of effective
effective way and the idea of course of
uh xiuyang which yoshi amongst other top
communists was very very keen on is of
course in many ways an inheritance of
that confucian learning which many of
the older leaders of the ccp had gone
through at that time at that time
uh at one point as youngsie puts it he
says we should read books just as often
as we sweep the floor
and with a rather mao-like analogy to
bodily function he then adds
i feel that my this is yang again i feel
that my pretty bourgeois weakness and
self-regard
is like the stinkiness of my toes it's
hard to wash away so while i have no
direct primary evidence of what young
city's socks were like i think at least
we can assume that they may have been a
little uh overly ideologically fervid in
this particular case
let me give you also a few thoughts from
um
liu yenjin the young woman born in 1923
a member actually also one of those ccp
uh military performance troops and
deeply in love with a man who actually
became a rather famous chinese movie
director link to fung who then married
someone else and the diary uh it is a
contemporary diary um is it's very
moving in many ways but also you can
tell that's written by someone in her
twenties in a moment of deep emotional
distress
one of the moments that she found very
very inspiring though was
the in aftermath of the japanese defeat
where she says you know taika paula oh
yeah oh boy amazing faced with this
victory
she's writing to herself she refers to
herself in the second person she says
the party needs you
to advance more quickly take on more
glorious tasks it does not need your
pessimistic saying
and
later on
she writes that
in her case my pretty bourgeois romantic
fantasies and inappropriate thoughts
should be put on the shelf and she cites
they're actually an often quoted
slightly misquoted uh take which is the
the leadiness theory of the glass of
water which you may know which is
basically a kind of slightly parodied
version that then put forward the
thoughts of alexandria columbia one of
the early feminist bolshevik thinkers
that
supposedly love and relationship should
be as ordinary as drinking a glass of
water or drinking from a bottle
in other words in a truly social society
it wouldn't become the source of this
huge romantic pretty bourgeois um kind
of um uh source of
distress or overly emotional um work
that it is in a petty bourgeois society
this is in fact a slight parody to be
honest of what colin tai said but that's
not so important in this particular
particular case and yet
when julian julian jin's love affair
goes horribly wrong when her um intended
marries someone else she writes a
furious entry in her diary at the time
and i think on international women's day
in fact in march 1946 and amongst the
things that she writes
along the kind of things that you might
expect from someone who's been deeply
hurt in love such as what kind of demon
is troubling your mind she says
why don't you have a bolshevik morality
about love you should use a robust party
spirit to evaluate yourself now i don't
know if you would write to your angry
lover i'm not asking you know words in
those terms but again the fact that at
this time in this place in this era for
a 20-something deep young woman deeply
deeply steeped in the way in which the
party is recasting its card race to use
this language about something that's
deeply personal to her and deeply deeply
felt and not in any sense inauthentic
and yet of course encased in what we
would regard as marxist jargon is a sign
of how important this recasting of
language was in terms of people's uh
people self-self-definition
let me um
conclude if i may with a
few thoughts at the end here about where
i think some of this
comes
comes together
people make propaganda and ideology to
misquote marx but they do not make it
exactly as they please
in other words
it's not enough just to understand as we
must do that the gomindang during the
period that we're talking about become
immensely
down-hearted
uh someone like one should yeah who
started with just you know very briefly
1947 he keeps writing things such as i
feel extremely gloomy about the future
of the current political situation and
you know the core people in our party
don't have any genuine conviction when
it comes to democracy and constitutional
government the ccp
diarists of that time have lots of quite
problematic things to say as i mentioned
which will probably mean that they would
be guilty of historical nihilism in the
present day but they don't say that sort
of thing there's a genuine emotional
register of difference between the the
two sides
but beyond that we have to understand
how that ideological fulfillment and
sense of self-creation links to an
objective reality
and consideration of today's nationalist
propaganda and marxist language and
there's plenty of it in china today is
often treated as if it's free-floating
and in some ways disconnected from
social realities but i think that is no
more true in the 2020s than it was in
the 1940s or indeed
vice versa
language that's used today whether it's
about communities of common destiny or
the desire for china to be a 21st
century marxist society
is mostly quite inwardly directed it is
for a chinese audience
but i think it is still a reminder the
fact that it doesn't translate very well
into english or into an international
audience which one of the reasons that
doesn't tend to get used much in china's
outward propaganda is nonetheless a
useful and necessary reminder that the
liberal subject
is not the norm
in all societies at all times in other
words we can't just translate the
documents important that they are we
need to understand the reception of that
language and the use of it to construct
identities in certain ways that
still have a great deal of of power
that in the end i think is why
that post-war moment
1945 to
1949
is i think increasingly relevant to the
moment that china is in today
um as you see the list that i have here
i won't go through every single one of
them but in terms of some of the
practical reasons why i think the late
1940s has an importance for the presence
of uh sorry the trajectory of china
today its role at the un uh its
territorial issues the idea of china as
a global actor a time of ideological
revolutionary renewal and identity ideas
of economic development moral balance
the idea of china as a world war ii
victor that gives it a right in the
world today you know all of these are
things that i think in practical terms
are important in linking the two periods
but i think also more conceptually
the post-war era has one other element
that is reflected in something that is
very relevant to today's language it too
was on the cusp of a new era one that
defined politics or redefined politics
in very significant ways and xi jinping
of course also has defined his period in
power as a new era albeit one that
simultaneously seeks some kind of
continuity with the founding of the
party back in 1921 as the resolution of
last november put put forward and
remembering that in china of all places
the politics of the future
is very closely linked to
interpretations of the recent and quite
distant past is i think one of the many
ideas that we can draw from to me that
very fascinating very short post-war
period
thank you all very much for your
attention and delighted to have some
discussion now arnold
thank you very much for a wonderful
wonderful presentation
lots of things to to discuss
um
while
people
gather their questions get their
thoughts
[Music]
on my classes so i can see who wants to
be her
i remember when i when i first started
looking for and then finding wang
shibuya's diaries in the
i think the jindai show yeah you saw at
actually
um
i thought i had had this was for my my
phd dissertation i thought i had a major
breakthrough when i was finally able to
locate them and then give the families
the families permission to actually use
them
and i came very excited to the library
one morning and discover that
most of them are written in sound search
so so in grass script which as a
graduate student i found
even more so now as a professor i guess
i found really difficult to describe the
cycle so i had to call on the help of
others to try to instruct me the
particular writing style
but when i did get to it i was struck by
just how fascinating those and how
personal
those diaries off in many ways much of
which was written of course when he held
high political office
but they are not just reflecting his
political positions and his political
participation they're also really very
introspective in terms of what they
contribute maybe i could start you off
with a question on that actually
or connecting to the whole issue of
identity that you that you bring up here
so
one of the things that i've spent quite
a bit of time thinking about
both when i was writing at this on this
time period but but particularly later
on
is the
preoccupation with the restitution of
china after the end of the anti-japanese
war as a kind of decolonization
that you see presented both by
uh republican leaders
and by communists
and this is extremely interesting in
many ways because it links china to a
broader world of decolonization that was
taking place at the same time
but it's also really striking in the
sense that this is the in many ways the
remnants of an empire
in the sense that the both republic of
china and the people's republic should
go over borders that were remarkably
similar to those of the empire
that is connecting itself to the issue
of decolonization so in other words it
is a decolonization by others uh that
needs to be undertaken there is
relatively little self-reflection
in terms of what actually constitutes
the republic that most of the
uh and others served with with such
research eminence so if that is also
part of the identity
challenge in a way here then and and and
perhaps also now in terms of the use of
concepts not these illegal terms the
imagination or the imaginary of what
this new new china should be
it's a great question arnold thank you
um i think one of the best case studies
which indeed is mentioned in
washington's diary but has a kind of
wider um
purchase as well is an event which i
think you know oh i think you know more
about the most people i think but which
is the um independence referendum for
outer mongolia that takes place very
early in late 1945 um and i think many
here will know just to say uh it was
organized by stalin
on stalin's behalf and it had a rather
miraculous result i think of sort of 437
000 people in mongolia voted for
independence and zero people voted
against it which was
not a single one so it was entirely free
and fair in in every way i'm sure there
was soon to be a similar uh vote in
luhansk and various other places uh too
as well but why is this interesting
because apart from the the astonishing
nature of the of the vote which clearly
was a gesture of contempt by stalin in a
sense towards the the chinese republic
in that case because for a very long
time
the republic of china had
continued to maintain its claim that was
lost in 1911 at the end of the qing to
outer mongolia as well as which again
essentially become a sort of soviet
satellite state um as a territory that
would have to be restored to the
republic in a way that taiwan and
various other places would do uh uh as
well and essentially of course it has
become the only one of those territories
to which the chinese state has
essentially given up its claim during
that period
and one of the reasons it seems to me
is that
a lot of the wider discussion during
that period
um is about
what you can
essentially what you can save as part of
a kind of central idea of what the
chinese republic is going to be and what
has to be let go
and
having to let go of mongolia essentially
as a price that you know
they can't be avoided and once you get
himself knows it's gonna be very very
difficult for um uh to get past the uh
you know the press and some of the more
firebrand members of the nationalist
party who don't want to let it go too
but because there's a concern in
particular the northeast and the north
west so xinjiang and
manchuria are going to uh come under
uh um uh under threat and in other words
eat away at that you know wider
territorial um uh vision of uh of
of china um it's put forward as a
sacrifice that must be made to uh to
save the rest in that um in that sense
there isn't much sense i think at least
i have seen very little sense of the
idea that there should be some reckoning
with china's own record in terms of this
period and i'm not entirely surprised
simply because one of the things that i
hope
i've drawn with the picture here and i
think you know he is evident in a sense
one one looks at it is that there are so
many different
defensive elements of trying to
construct this state at the same time
and even these attempts to you know
in a sense
the appeals to molotov and to burns and
to turn up in paris and london and say
we should be saying what goes on with
italy's colonies is actually part of
that exercise too you know it's part of
this sort of wider claim that actually
there is this new entity that is a
post-war china that has a right to do
this that and the the other i think
there's also
and this i'm stretching slightly because
i i don't at the moment have a
particular quote i could put my hand on
to do that although i should look for
one but i suspect there's a strong
feeling
that if the british
and the french
do not reside in any sense from their
empires and you know india aside they
really don't during this period and that
is something that is observed quite
strongly by the chinese during this
period then the sense that looking at
the moat in their own eye is a useful
task at this point i think is probably
not something that's regarded as a great
political priority at this particular uh
this particular stage but i mean i think
you'll write that it is a
while there's lots of insight on various
things the sense of reflexiveness on the
nature of what exactly the republic is
supposed to be
um almost doesn't give enough space to
breathe during that time i think
it is quite
connected to other
periods of transition of the great wars
i mean those of us who read
uh putin's
speech in which he justifies the
takeover by violence
or an armed force of ukraine spends an
enormous amount of time castigating
lenin and to some extent stalin as well
for having done your staff for thinking
about russia as an empire in which
people who were not central to them or
actually had rights but you would never
find out of the chinese chinese
communism
okay
other questions
yes
[Music]
political views and everything
um
actually i was rather doing the opposite
which is pointing out that um
actually language and mindset makes a
huge amount of difference at this at
this time because the sort of language
that you would get amongst these younger
and not so young cadres is not at all
the kind of language that would have
been used in that form by the kind of
figures on the nationalist side who have
their own political language and very
strong people like zhang jingua or
indeed
or uh
uh or chun bulay actually uh uh chiang
kai-shek's personal secretary in a sense
who eventually takes his own life in in
1948 through a combination of sort of
depression uh that comes from you know
personal
mental health issues but also with the
kind of collapse of the regime around
him at that uh at that time but much of
the language in which they express their
own kind of growing sense of gloom and
despair is a as you would know chloe
very well kind of quite traditional sort
of confusion self-presentation that's in
some ways you know rather rejecting of
this idea of self-realization and
changing through ideas that come from
from a marxist a marxist framework in
that uh
in that sense i think that one of the
things that
could do with more emphasis during this
particular period because it's one of
the rare periods when you get not quite
a sort of even conflict but certainly
one with a sort of strong elements on on
both sides
is the way in which the post-war period
is one of different sorts of political
visions that are expressed in different
sorts of political language to socialize
the people who are putting them forward
and one of the areas that i didn't talk
about partly because i thought you
wouldn't well thank you for going on for
three hours but there's quite a lot
about land reform actually the tour
guide program during this time where
actually lots of these people are
recording first of all really
interesting things about how you know
again in retrospect it's all about the
peasants uh you know rise up against
their evil oppressors and there's
actually plenty of that going on but
also a great deal of it is spent in a
way that isn't always so much stressed
in communists basically giving other
communists a hard time about not being
sufficiently um kind of indoctrinated
into the program and having the right
kind of
the wrong kind of rightist or the right
kind of leftist viewpoint as as part of
that but the consequence of these things
were not by any means purely abstract
they ended in real people being locked
up or you know hit with bill hooks or
you know murdered in the in in front of
their their neighbors in in in front of
the uh uh
uh
in front of other other other farmers so
these things have a real sort of context
in that in that sense so get to the
question was that to something
yep
yes
i really um
enjoyed it i wanted to ask you maybe to
reflect a bit more on the um this
concept of the chinese floor and
particularly the ending for it which it
sounds like you're sticking with 1949
um oh no no no no no absolutely not so
thank you for letting me before that but
sorry let me finish your question
cause i was wondering um
one thing that i think comes up a lot in
the japanese cases the endless debates
of when the vote were actually yes when
does single actually end do you have the
answer to that because i don't well and
i think one thing you know it varies a
lot by geography like okinawa's postwar
is very different than mainland japan's
post war and you know succulent and the
carol islands post war is still ongoing
or whatever um but it's also you know a
historical question that comes up again
and again again is the
occupation is it the olympics is it the
oil crisis is it the death of you know
emperor and so forth so i'm wondering
you know maybe that's too much to
realize just talk maybe try to address
all of that but i was wondering how much
we see in 1949 or perhaps some other day
as a moment when all of this stuff gets
put on hold for a while and we enter
kind of a different period of the
cultural evolution or the vows period or
whatever or whether you see sort of
continuities in certain areas of china
or certain areas of chinese politics
that's very open-ended
i mean just as i think one level just as
you've said the japanese single or
indeed the european post war doesn't
have an obvious end point and indeed you
know whether the russian um uh assault
on ukraine is going to prove as many
people are saying the end of a
particular sort of personal order is
something we're debating you know as we
as we speak right right right now um
i think the answer is it's certainly i
don't i personally don't intend it to be
1949 it's not meant to be literally just
the sort of the four years of the week
after period but i do think of it as
something that obviously has the civil
war at the heart of it because how could
it not but that stretches beyond that at
least into the mid 1950s i think the
idea of it is this that the forces that
are unleashed by the circumstances of
the very long war with japan
are not worked through
certainly by 1949 i mean it says many of
the things that emerge at that point not
least a split between
the mainland and taiwan are products of
the forces that are unleashed at that
particular time but one of the things
that i think new work is beginning to
really get to grips with is the idea
that in some ways the fact that you have
these split jurisdictions and
legitimacies between the mainland and
taiwan really matter in some quite
important ways i mean i think i can say
without giving names and things but i
think they're gonna there's gonna be a
postdoc coming to our honors program
during next year whose doctoral thesis i
examined at cambridge university and
it's a fascinating study of in
particular the way in which various
types of sort of communist and
anti-communist legitimacy are sought in
the global south or third world we might
say
by taiwan and the prc i think the idea
that perhaps existed even a little while
ago that once it was on the island the
taiwan government had no time or
interest in anything except trying to
shore up its own position and you know
oppressing dissidents both of which it
did do to a very extensive extent but
also had really quite a strong idea of
itself as an actor in the world an actor
that was part of an anti-communist front
an actor that was still a postcolonial
actor in its own right
so hence the connections with all these
slightly dodgy folks like sigmund re and
uh you know baldai and so forth continue
to be uh to be important and also
actually an alternative economic act as
well one of the great ironies of the
post-war is that
land reform under chiang kai-shek goes
really well it's just it goes really
well on taiwan with american support
once he's actually got away from the
mainland where it'd be an absolute
disaster on his path and land reform a
very different sword is then offered in
the mainland as a challenge to asia and
indeed beyond asia as well as you know
in vietnam and uh and other parts of an
emergent revolutionary situation in
southeast asia even for some time into
the 1950s
the colonial challenge
to the republic of china as indeed to
the people's republic is still there
malaya malaysia doesn't become
independent until 1957. um you have
vietnam wars you know first with the
french and then with the americans and
then indeed with the chinese
eventually in other words all of the
agendas that shape the global post-war
or even the global cold war i suppose
continue to be of relevance to the
political projects that are underway
both in the mainland of china and in
taiwan even if they're not always of
equal valencia and equal equal
significance but they both matter at
that time because they're they're in
that world making the case and also
pushing forward agendas that clearly
suit them uh better than
uh
better than their
supposed to opponents two questions the
first question regarding your
i think the question regarding uh
reducing
the vmt and i was wondering i'm very
much convinced out there i guess the
self-reflection they are trying to
practice
the question is how much
we see this kind of process as they are
being part of the product from the yen
years when the yen campaign was just
kind of started in 42-45
and giving such i think they have this
part of
continuity i was wondering how much
can we see us as kind of independent of
the revolutionary renewal or
identity process themselves
by product of the process during the
young campaign
and
see during the kind of the china
possible the second question is i feel i
guess you have been discussing the
nationalist texting for top
and also the communist cultures and i
wonder kind of
during the postwar there's also the
third past
intellectual kind of debate
so
and those sorts of people right
this kind of intellectual defense
[Music]
yeah you had two great questions well
let me try and briefly sorry i know
we're getting to time as well but i'll
try to give a brief answer to to each of
them i think the first and i think
you're actually right um i don't think
with these sorts of very very kind of
strongly committed revolutionaries it
certainly doesn't begin in the post-war
period you know they have this very long
engagement with the revolution from you
know their teenage years from the 1920s
and 30s onwards and again i didn't have
you know remotely enough time to talk
about it but each of the well in
particular it's untrue but also to some
extent you're indeed they have long and
quite complex personal lives
as with all you know revolutionaries
that are linked with their revolutionary
lines as well and one of the elements
again that i only talked about in
passing but in the study that i'm doing
i think is in a sense become more
important for me
is perhaps not surprising and somewhat
depressing but nonetheless you know
necessary um discovery in the in
historically necessary discovery that
gender really makes a difference um the
experience of young revolutionary women
in the 1930s and 40s even ones like jung
who you know run off in their teenage
years and
taking part in some pretty violent
activities are still given a much harder
time by party leaders than young men in
that particular position and that
becomes visible over and over again so i
think in terms of that construction i'd
say it's certainly a very long term
thing but actually you know gender is
yet another one of the frameworks that i
think shapes that experience and that's
why i thought it was very important to
make sure that you know at least a
significant amount of the revolution
experience that one considers during
this period is from women as well as
from from men
um in terms of that third force of
intellectuals um
i mean i've been doing some reading on
some of the people one of the people who
again is very well known but sometimes
some of his specifics
um are not always studied as they might
be politics he wrote so much it's young
and
he because
in a sense for english-speaking
scholarly readers he's been
characterized as the last confusion you
know dialito's famous book um but
in a sense he is that but he's much more
as well in various ways and one of the
interesting things and again arnold
because you know everything on pound is
very things but when a youngster mean
kind of takes this sort of flight to
meet mao and these other guys when
they're still in yemen about 1946 and
sort of has a long chat with them and
there's this wonderful scene in which
youngster me explains in great detail
this very very complex political system
that he thinks is going to sort of
navigate between um you know
western-style government which he
doesn't think is going to work in china
and a bolshevik style government which
he doesn't think is going to work in
china and the guamindang which you know
he hates as well and thinks that's not
going to work and it's
lots he makes comparisons with you know
what's happening in the united nations
which is just being set up at that time
and uh you know what you can take from
uh ferrari's traditional chinese things
anyway takes a long time he's talking to
mao zedong he's talking to george he's
talking lots of really top people and
then at the end he stops this is his own
you know regulation of it so he's
telling against himself
and there's just silence and all these
top communist leaders are like staring
at him and then finally um i think it's
actually trudeau says
ah
so it took you 30 years to work that out
did it
and they turn onto other subjects quite
uh quite quickly so there's definitely a
willingness to hear but whether or not
people actually
react to some of these people i think
unfortunately is is not as obvious in
that that case but it's interesting to
see that the efforts that they they made
and i think that by no means as as as
really as needful are being dismissed as
they sometimes are they were an
important part of a much richer debate
than sometimes sometimes realized
i think one more question
but that
i'm just going to come forward a little
bit louder so um i think it's
fascinating that you're able to work
with a lot of personal writings and
diaries um and my question
is habit but those also required by
local institutions like military schools
i'm just wondering when we work with
this kind of sources as the story is how
do we acknowledge the background and
some potential bias that the writers
might have and how to deal with that
[Music]
in this yeah and also the juxtaposition
of diaries
in some ways all of them are about
calling it to be
a new kind of world whether it's
what is
the audience from the diaries and then
i guess the larger question is
how
how is the act of writing different from
the act of speaking
um
great now thanks to two wonderful
questions to to finish off with in
related related areas
um
i mean no diaries or no personal
accounts of any sort are in any sense
pure or unmediated or authentic
everything is constructed in some
particular idea and one of the reasons i
gave a quick sort of drive-by shooting
to the idea of the liberal subject and
hey i'm a liberal subject i love the
liberal subject is that we do we you
know university educated ivy league type
people living in the western world
speaking english tend to assume it's
normative and that other things are
deviations or anomalies from them eg the
construction of the mind of a young
communist cadre in the 1940s so part of
what i was trying to do is point out
that
not there's any sense in which these
things are not constructed i mean one of
the part of the answer to your question
is that at that time one of the ways in
which you're expected to self-discipline
is to write personal accounts and
particularly in the case of you know
mid-level cadres and others they would
quite often be read and inspected and
discussed by senior officers um
elsewhere as well so the idea these are
purely private documents um wouldn't
necessarily be the case i would
recommend by the way the fantastic book
writing war by aaron moore erin william
moore which is about different types of
chinese japanese and indeed american
service people's diaries service men's
diaries mostly and how um
they are used to try and sort of both
mediate through a professional
obligation and a sense of creation of
the uh
of of the self but i think one of the
things and i think the answer to the
other answer question is how can we kind
of use them productively
i think it's true as of all these sorts
of sources that you read
you have to read against the grain and
there's the phrase that has become the
the stock one but it's useful in this
sense and in particular case the things
that i think they are useful for
are things like understanding where the
flaws and difficulties in the revolution
come about they're later smoothed out by
the idea that actually everything the
party does you know goes well and that
everyone follows the
revolutionary path and one of the things
that is clearest across these very
different diaries from different people
in different parts of china at various
times is that the revolution surprise
surprise was not a smooth and easy
progress process and had a lot of
complexities within it during that time
but the one thing
i think we probably can't do and we can
you know i think may take pride in
having to work around this is that you
know unlikely above on rancour the idea
of vegan vs argentine you know how it
really was
that isn't really what people's
construction of themselves
does
because everything is going to be
mediated through a set of positions you
know whether it's gender or class or
geography or emotion which i think is
one of the really important ones it is
really different reading diary ex
entrances from chenboule who's a senior
man who is suffering a mental health
issue that eventually will help him you
know force him to to take his own life
and the work of the writings of a 23
year old woman who is having a um you
know very very bad personal life
experience at that time in terms of her
uh relationship but on the other hand is
part of what she perceives and
repeatedly um defines herself as being
part of an ongoing transformative
project of which she's very enthusiastic
to be a part and all these things are
visible in terms the way in which they
present themselves but they're not
simply capable i think of being
separated out as being either sort of
positive or negative or supportive or
unsupportive of a particular political
project that they're more complex than
that
thank you very much i was also thinking
about the gender dimensions
and the significance for trying to
understand
uh
periods of tremendous change that's the
one one that you are dealing with it
through being able to listen to women's
voices from in different positions and
different situations
and and often even today that is not
done i mean it was one of the things
that struck me when i worked on the
civil war era in china was a uh
period of
breakthroughs for women that was i mean
in organizational terms but also also in
much broader terms
in intellectual life in terms of what
went on in the countryside
so maybe we could have you back when
when this
when this project is
[Music]
lecture today